-Performing "Easy Lover,"
one of my favorites,
Ellie Goulding, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ It was never easy, lover ♪
♪ When you've given all you've
got to each other ♪
♪ And then every time,
it's harder to recover ♪
-♪ We were only young ♪
♪ We were only young ♪
-♪ It was never easy, lover ♪
♪ I just wanted you to
hold, hold me closer ♪
♪ Yet, it always seems to
go even further ♪
-♪ We were only young ♪
♪ We were only young ♪
♪ And I've been walking in
a straight line,
finding this again ♪
♪ But every time I leave,
you pull me back in ♪
-♪ Easy lover ♪
♪ Keep it cool on me ♪
♪ Don't be cruel to me ♪
♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
♪ Keep it cool on me ♪
♪ Give it all to me ♪
♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
-♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
-♪ Easy lover ♪
-♪ To be honest ♪
♪ If we were able ♪
♪ To be together ♪
♪ Maybe something fatal ♪
♪ But I need your touch
right here on the table ♪
-♪ We were only young ♪
♪ We were only young ♪
♪ And I've been walking in
a straight line,
finding this again ♪
♪ But every time I leave,
you pull me back in ♪
-♪ Easy lover ♪
♪ Keep it cool on me ♪
♪ Don't be cruel to me ♪
♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
♪ Keep it cool on me ♪
♪ Give it all to me, yeah ♪
♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
-♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
-♪ Easy lover ♪
-♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
-♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
-♪ Easy lover ♪
♪ It's gone too far,
I'm too deep, I can't sleep ♪
♪ I'm still foolishly
in love with you ♪
♪ Just like all the other girls
you promised ♪
♪ I can't stop believin'
you want me ♪
♪ And you're foolishly in love ♪
♪ But you're not,
so I take a shot ♪
-♪ Easy lover ♪
♪ Oh, keep it cool on me ♪
♪ Don't be cruel to me ♪
♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
♪ Keep it cool on me ♪
♪ Give it all to me, yeah ♪
♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
-♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
♪ Keep it cool on me ♪
♪ 'Cause I know
you've done it before ♪
♪ Easy lover ♪
-♪ Ah, ah, ah ♪
-♪ Easy lover ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!